Hidden columns essentially
hides columns based on
their importance as
the viewports size gets smaller.
Let's see how you might do this
with a baseball scoreboard.
As you can see all of the data is there.
The short name, the long name and
the runs scored during each of
the innings plus the final score.
I'm going to start small and ask myself
what's the most important information.
In this case, I'm going to go with
the short team name and the final score.
I'm going to use display none,
to hide everything else.
Then as the viewport size gets bigger,
let's swap out the full team name and
start showing each of
the runs per inning.
The biggest problem of hidden columns
is that you're hiding content
from the user.
What happens if I need to know how many
runs were scored in the 7th inning?
If I'm a device with a narrow viewport,
it's just not there, I can't see it.
So use this technique with caution.
And if possible, use abbreviated data
instead of hiding it completely.